68到92
68 92
同为108 120
单长35
裤长95
这个39扣5
39块扣5扣5
39扣个5
来这一条
这个垂直感也好
你看这个版型好看不
矮喽是吗
矩指96
矩指4
矮喽是吗
这个牌
来这个腰围
腰围是72
垂围
垂围110
单长36
裤长92
来这个39扣6
裤子两边是装饰的几个小裤子
版型很好
这一款
39块
扣6扣6
72的一个平铺
矮喽是吗
这是啥牌子
这样子的
来这个39块
扣6扣6
39扣6扣6
来这个黑色矮喽是吗
黑色黑色的这一条
后半边送你
矮喽是吗
矩指64
人棉32
矩扬指4
来腰围74
74-90
垂围
垂围110 120
单长
单长35
裤长是95
这个有要的扣
来39块
扣5扣5
大扣腿大扣腿的
39扣5
直筒的应该算是
直筒
39扣5
来这个M码一个灯音容的
送了一个扣子
然后面料是这样子的
看没
灯音容呢
一块面料的
M码矩指98
矩扬指2
矩指98
矩指
不对
绵98
我一摇一摇晕了都
矩扬指2
M码M码
绵98的
腰围66
66-88
臀围
臀围98-110
单长34
裤长97
来这个39块
扣1扣1
39 39
扣个1
直筒的灯音容的这一条
39扣个1
来这个浅色牛仔
浅色浅色牛仔
这一条
看看
这个有一点点微辣的
我感觉
有一点微辣的一个裤腿
两边直插钩
来腰围
腰围的话是64
64-82
臀围100-110
100-110
单长35
裤长是100
裤长100
这个裤
这个标了个小字标
这个应该是有一点点黄着点
看没
腰这有一点点微黄
这个29
扣1
29块
扣1扣1
这个是棉多少
我看一下
S码
S的棉70
巨指23
人棉6
圈子1
来这个29块
微微小
这个基本上就不算瑕疵了
都有一点点微黄
它贴了个瑕疵标
就给人家放个福利
这个在腰上
这个不管你裤子扎在腰里
还是放在外面
都能给它盖上这里
扣1扣1
这个超划算
这个瑕疵
这个瑕疵很好
这个瑕疵特别好
39开
没有喜欢的吗
扣1
扣2
扣3
扣4
扣5
扣6
扣7
扣8
扣9
扣10
扣11
扣12
扣13
扣14
扣15
扣16
扣17
扣18
扣19
扣20
扣21
扣22
扣23
扣24
扣25
扣26
扣27
扣28
扣29
扣30
扣31
扣32
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣38
扣39
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣44
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣48
扣49
扣50
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣55
扣56
扣57
扣58
扣59
扣60
扣61
扣62
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣38
扣39
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣44
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣48
扣49
扣50
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣55
扣56
扣57
扣58
扣59
扣60
扣61
扣62
扣63
扣64
扣65
扣67
扣68
扣69
扣70
扣71
扣72
扣73
扣74
扣75
扣76
扣78
扣79
扣80
扣81
扣82
扣83
扣94
扣95
扣96
扣97
扣98
扣90
扣91
扣92
扣93
扣94
扣95
扣96
扣97
扣98
扣90
扣91
扣92
扣93
扣94
扣95
扣97
扣98
扣99
扣10
扣11
扣12
扣13
扣14
扣15
扣16
扣17
扣18
扣19
扣20
扣21
扣22
扣23
扣24
扣25
扣26
扣27
扣28
扣29
扣30
扣31
扣32
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣38
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣44
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣48
扣49
扣50
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣55
扣56
扣57
扣58
扣59
扣60
扣61
扣62
扣32
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
扣37
扣38
扣39
扣40
扣41
扣42
扣43
扣44
扣45
扣46
扣47
扣48
扣49
扣50
扣51
扣52
扣53
扣54
扣55
扣56
扣57
扣58
扣59
扣60
扣61
扣62
扣63
扣54
扣56
扣57
扣58
扣59
扣60
扣61
扣62
扣63
扣64
扣65
扣67
扣68
扣69
扣70
扣71
扣72
扣73
扣74
扣75
扣76
扣78
扣79
扣80
扣81
扣92
扣93
扣94
扣95
扣96
扣97
扣98
扣90
扣91
扣92
扣93
扣94
扣95
扣96
扣97
扣99
扣10
扣11
扣12
扣13
扣14
扣15
扣17
扣18
扣19
扣20
扣21
扣22
扣23
扣24
扣25
扣26
扣27
扣28
扣29
扣30
扣31
扣32
扣33
扣34
扣35
扣36
来这个黑色
正值的一个半身裙
黑色
后面是开叉
全松拧
黑色黑色的
腰围64到96
腿围
腿围106128
裙长80
这个29
29扣0
真值的
29块
扣0扣0
黑色黑色的
一条半身裙
29块
扣0扣0
29扣个0
来这个是一个西装短裤
黑色
裤腿的话是双层的一个裤腿
来腰围
腰围72 74
72 74
平围98 104
裆长33
裤长54
9块
扣个8
9块扣8
是一个短裤
9块扣8扣8
这个裤刚刚裤了一条
刚刚灰色裙多长呢
我给你量一样
苹果气泡你来啦
欢迎欢迎
昨天你要的啥样的粉色裙
我咋想不起来
瞎打电话给我
我没想起来是啥样的
小短裙了
这个短裙
短裤款式有没牛仔的
或者白色的
没有
来这个灰色
灰色我给你量量
胸围的话是94 96
94 96的胸围
长度是90
长度90的
小苹果
苹果气泡可以穿吗
19给你
含毛的这个摸上去是含毛的
距离含多少我不知道
里面没有洗标了
我没看见洗标刚刚
看里面有内衬
你这买的肉粉色一下子走出来两条
我是不是是不是是一个到膝盖一个长度
那个粉色的到膝盖底下一丢丢就算到膝盖吧
那个小短裤小短裙是不是那一条
我一下子没想起来
我后来想起来是不是那一个
那个还在走还没找到
你不说还还想要吗
我一直没找到
瞎问我我现在懵了
不知道是哪一个了
能穿我这个19
1919我再给你注意着点呢
小短裙里面看还有不
19块能穿扣衣
含毛的这个是里面有内衬
不显肚子
不显屁股
那个很好是吧
现在好像还没走出来那个可以吗
这个是
来367367
小黄油367
OK谢谢
来367
最好看
invited
OK
好的
谢谢
远古没有白色也没见有牛仔的
来这个
这个是一个粉色
刚刚过到了一个
这个是一个哈林裤
粉色的一条哈林裤
两边是斜扎裤带
前面有裤有风机裤
有蓝链
来腰围
腰围是64 68
64 68
平围100 110
裆长
裆长36
裆长是90
这个9块钱给你们
9块9块
扣6扣6
这个粉色的哈林裤
9块钱9块钱
扣6扣6
9块钱扣个6
来这个大蓝色的一条
连一圈
短袖
镂空的
袖子镂空
身上有内衬
蕾丝蕾丝的这个
这个是啥牌子
我一直记不住
腰上是松紧腰
来这个胸围
胸围96 106
96 106
裆长是113
这个19块
扣3扣3
这个原来是39的一个圈
因为这个来货比较多
给你们放19了
现在19 19扣3扣3
19扣个3
今天早上吃的包子太咸了
好想喝水
来这个卫衣
莲帽的这一款卫衣
莲帽的一款卫衣
前面有那个
那个叫啥吗
前面